>>> YOU COULD Y THERE WERE
PLENTY OF WARNING SIGNS THAT
TRUMP WOULD KE THIS COUNTRY
DOWN THE TUBES.
NO, I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT THE
PORTABLE TOILETS BROUGHT IN FOR
THE 2017 INAUGURATION OF DONALD
JOHN TRUMP.
YOU MAY REMEMBER THE NAME.
DON'S JOHNS.
AND I'M NOT REFERRING TO THE
TIME TRUMP WAS CAUGHT ON CAMERA
WITH WHAT APPEARED TO BE A SCRAP
OF PAPER HANGING ON HIS SHOE.
NO, I THINK IT WAS HIS FIXATION
WITH GOVERNMENT REGULATIONS ON
TOILETS.
>> PEOPLE ARE FLUSHING TEN
TIMES, 15 TIMES, AS OPPOSED TO
ONCE.
>> YES, IT'S ALL STARTING TO ADD
UP.
CONSIDER THE LATEST REVELATION
FROM MAGGIE HABERMAN.
HE WRITES THAT TRUMP WOULD
REPEATEDLY TEAR UP SENSITIVE
WHITE HOUSE DOCUMENTS AND
ATTEMPT TO FLUSH THEM DOWN THE
TOILET.
WHITE HOUSE ENGINEERS REPORTEDLY
FOUND WADS OF PAPER CLOGGING THE
SYSTEM.
I KNOW WHAT YOU'RE THINKING.
THE JOKES WRITE THEMSELVES.
DID THEY FIND THE CONSTITUTION
OR THE LONG AWAITED HEALTHCARE
PLAN JAMMING UP THE PIPES?
IT'S AS IF THEY WERE FRANTICALLY
SEARCHING FOR HILLARY CLINTON'S
E-MAILS.
>> IF I DELETED ONE E-MAIL LIKE
A LOVE NOTE TO MELANIA, IT'S THE
ELECTRIC CHAIR FOR TRUMP.
>> SHE DELETED HER E-MAILS.
PEOPLE GO TO JAIL FOR THAT.
>> NOBODY'S EVER HEARD OF IT.
DON'T BLEACH THEIR E-MAILS OR
DESTROY EVIDENCE TO KEEP IT FROM
BEING PUBLICLY ARCHIVED AS
REQUIRED UNDER FEDERAL LAW.
>> NOW TRUMP IS DOING A LOT OF
SPINNING IN RESPONSE TO WATER
CLOSET GATE, INSISTING HE NEVER
FLUSHED WHITE HOUSE DOCUMENTS
AND DENYING ANY MISHANDLING OF
HIS OFFICIAL RECORDS.
PERHAPS HE'S WORRIED ABOUT ALL
OF THOSE CHANTS OF LOCK HER UP
COMING BACK TO HAUNT HIM.
>> E-MAILS WHICH PUT AMERICA'S
ENTIRE NATIONAL SECURITY AT
RISK.
AND TO THINK SHE WAS HERE
YESTERDAY.
I GUESS SHE DIDN'T DO VERY WELL.
>> I'M TELLING YOU, THAT BIDEN
FAMILY, AND OTHERS, THAT BIDEN
FAMILY IS CORRUPT.
YOU SHOULD LOCK THEM UP.
LOCK UP THE BIDENS.
LOCK UPHILLRY.
LOCK THEM UP.
>> TRUMP WAS SO OBSESSED WITH
DOCUMENT DESTRUCTION THAT HE
SUGGESTED NANCY PELOSI BROKE THE
LAW WHEN SHE RIPPED UP THE
FORMER PRESIDENT'S STATE OF THE
UNION ADDRESS.
>> I THOUGHT IT WAS A TERRIBLE
THING WHEN SHE RIPPED UP THE
SPEECH.
FIRST OF ALL, IT'S AN OFFICIAL
DOCUMENT.
YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED.
IT'S ILLEGAL WHAT SHE DID.
SHE BROKE THE LAW.
>> NO, PELOSI TEARING UP TRUMP'S
SPEECH IS PERFECTLY LEGAL, BUT
TRUMP'S HANDLING OF OFFICIAL
DOCUMENTS IS ANOTHER MATTER.
A SOURCE SAYS THE NATIONAL
ARCHIVES IS NOW SEEKING A
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT INVESTIGATION
INTO WHETHER TRUMP VIOLATED THE
PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS ACT, WHICH
REQUIRES ALL RECORDS CREATED BY
PRESIDENTS BE TURNED OVER AT THE
END OF THEIR ADMINISTRATIONS.
ACCORDING TO THE "NEW YORK
TIMES," OFFICIALS BELIEVE TRUMP
MAY HAVE TAKEN CLASSIFIED
MATERIAL WITH HIM.
"THE WASHINGTON POST" HAS ALSO
REPORTED THAT SOME DOCUMENTS
MARKED TOP SECRET HAVE TURNED UP
AT MAR-A-LAGO.
THE JANUARY th COMMITTEE SAYS
THERE ARE GAPS IN WHITE HOUSE
PHONE LOGS FROM THE DAY OF THE
INSURRECTION, EVEN THOUGH WE
KNOW HE MADE SOME PHONE CALLS.
OH, DONNY BOY.
THE PIPES ARE CALLING.
IF DOCUMENT PRESENTATION
HYPOCRISY WERE AN OLYMPIC SPORT,
TRUMP WOULD EASILY TAKE HOME THE
GOLD, WHICH HAS ME THINKING
ABOUT THIS.
TRUMP AND HIS BUDDIES SHOULD
THINK ABOUT HOSTING THEIR OWN
WINTER GAMES.
THERE ARE SOME MAJOR PLAYERS TO
WATCH.
LIKE KEVIN McCARTHY SPEEDSKATING
PAST QUESTIONS ABOUT THE RNC
LABELING JANUARY 6th AT
LEGITIMATE POLITICAL DISCOURSE.
THEN THERE'S THE TANYA HARDING
OF THE HOUSE GOP, MARJORIE
TAYLOR GREENE, WHO DISCOVERED A
FLY IN HER CANNED TALKING POINTS
AFTER IT WAS TOO LATE.
>> NOT ONLY DO WE HAVE THE D.C.
JAIL, BUT NOW WE HAVE NANCY
PELOSI'S POLICE SPYING ON
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS, SPYING ON
THE LEGISLATIVE WORK WE DO.
SPYING ON OUR STAFF AND SPYING
ON AMERICAN CITIZENS THAT WANT
TO COME TALK TO THEIR
REPRESENTATIVES.
>> AS SOME OBSERVERS NOTED,
FIRST GESPACHO POLICE, WHAT'S
NEXT?
SANGRIA LAW?
PERHAPS TED CRUZ CAN COMPETE.
CANCUN IS PROBABLY TOO WARM FOR
THE OLYMPIC, UNLESS THERE'S A
TEQUILA LUGE.
BUT THE GAMES WOULD FIT IN WITH
THE AUTOCRATIC TENDENCIES.
THE MAGA OLYMPICS COULD FOLLOW
WITH A BEIJING INDUSTRIAL PARK.
NOT TO MENTION ITS APPALLING
HUMAN RIGHTS RECORD.
THE RUSSIANS ARE DOING QUITE
WELL IN BEIJING IF YOU OVERLOOK
ITS 15-YEAR-OLD FIGURE SKATER
WHO WE JUST LEARNED TURNED UP
POSITIVE FOR A BANNED SUBSTANCE
IN DECEMBER.
ASTOUNDING WHEN YOU CONSIDER
THAT THE RUSSIANS ARE COMPETING
AT THE RUSSIA OLYMPIC COMMITTEE
AFTER THEY RECEIVED A BAN.
NO WONDER RUSSIA THINKS IT CAN
GET AWAY WITH BULLYING UKRAINE.
NOT EVEN PUNISHED FOR CHEATING
IN SPORTS.
AS FOR OUR OWN CHEATER IN CHIEF
BACK HERE IN THE U.S., TRUMP
DOES NOT SEEM VERY WORRIED AS IF
HIS PUNISHMENT IS BEING DECIDED
BY THE OLYMPIC COMMITTEE RATHER
THAN THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
PERHAPS IF 2024, TRUMP COULD RUN
UNDER THE TIC.
THE TRUMP INSURRECTION
COMMITTEE.
HE COULD BRING HOME YET ANOTHER
GOLD TOILET.
BUT HONESTLY, THIS IS WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN YOU ALLOW SOMEONE
LIKE TRUMP TO CLOG T